In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for June 5th, on which we commemorate St. Boniface,
a Possil of Germany.
Our Holy Father Boniface, first called Winfred, was born in about 673 in Kreditan near Exeter
at the Western edge of Wessex, one of the kingdoms of the Anglo-Saxon Heptarchy.
From his earliest youth, he showed an inclination to the monastic life, and at the age of 7 entered
a monastery, first in Exeter, and then at Nursling, to be instructed both in the scriptures
and in secular disciplines.
At the end of brilliant studies, he was made a teacher, but the teaching of grammar and rhetoric
had for him no goal but as a preparation for the understanding of the scriptures.
A true monk, he also showed an ardent zeal for preaching, and dreamed of following
the example of the holy Irish monks who had left their homeland to travel about and preach
the good news to the pagans.
Sometime after his ordination to the priesthood in 716, he left the monastery of Nursling,
with three companions to join St. Willibrod's mission to Frigia.
This mission was encountering numerous obstacles, and the bishop had been forced to retire to
his monastery in the face of the pagan reaction provoked by the death of King Pippin of Herastol.
The new missionaries encountered the same difficulties, and soon had to return to their monastery
in England, where the brethren warmly welcomed Winfred and asked him to succeed the recently
deceased abbot.
Through the support of the bishop of Winchester, the saint was able to free himself from this
obligation and prepare a new mission, first making a pilgrimage to Rome in 718.
Pope Gregory II received him with honor, and desiring to continue the missionary work of
his glorious namesake Gregory I gave him a letter of investiture for the evangelization
of the pagan peoples of Germany that depended on the Roman sea.
And to mark this allegiance changed his name to Boniface in 719.
After having quickly crossed Bavaria and Thurungia, the saint moved again towards Frigia, where
St. Willibrod had succeeded in regaining his sea of Utrecht.
For three years he helped the old man to restore Christianity in that land, but when Willibrod
suggested that he ordained Boniface bishop to succeed him, he replied that he had been given
the mission to evangelize all the barbaric peoples, and that it was time for him to turn
to the lands of Germany that were still very little Christianized.
He therefore pushed more deeply into these lands, into regions under Frankish domination, but
still largely pagan.
In Hesse he began by founding a monastery at Ammonburg, which became a loadstone and a center for
the formation of missionaries.
When the Pope learned of Boniface's success, he summoned him to Rome and consecrated him
bishop, without assignment to a diocese, and directly under the authority of the Roman sea
in 722.
On his return to Hesse he resumed his missionary journeys and gained a resounding victory over
the pagans, by felling an oak tree sacred to the god Thor, from the idolaters venerated
as holding up the vault of the heavens.
Seeing him do this, the furious crowd rushed on him, but the tree suddenly bent under an invisible
hand and fell in four pieces at the saint's feet.
Boniface used the wood from the sacred tree to build a church, beside which he founded
the monastery of Fritzler.
As conversions multiplied, the saint left his disciples to continue his work and went to
Therengia in 724, where he also began his mission with the founding of Ammon's monastery at
Ordreff, near Gotha, and a number of women's monasteries.
To organize these new communities on traditional foundations, he appealed for monks and nuns
from England, who spread a broad in these regions, not only the gentleness of living
according to the gospel, but also the light of civilization.
Having received the rank of Archbishop and the palium from Pope Gregory III in 731, the
indefatigable apostle directed his energies to Bavaria, the largest of the German lands
that had long been evangelized by valiant missionaries, but still lacked a stable ecclesiastical
organization.
He placed four bishops there in Salzburg, Frazing, Radosban, and Passat.
Then returned to Rome to present the results of his mission to the Pope and receive his
directives.
On returning to Germany, furnished with holy relics and letters of recommendation from
the Pope, he placed bishops in Hess and Therengia.
The task proved to be more difficult than in Bavaria, because these lands had not inherited
Roman administrative organization and had no real towns that could serve as bishops in 741.
Once having completed these missions, after twenty years of labor, he was able to present
the organization of the new church to the new Pope, Zachariah.
To set a seal on this work, the saint decided to found in the center of the four lands that
he had evangelized, Frigia, Hess, Therengia, and Bavaria, a great monastery that would symbolize
the unity of the German church and could serve him as a residence.
After long searching his disciple Strum found a suitable place in the thick forest, crossed
by the river Folda, which gave its name to the new foundation.
Each year Saint Boniface would go there to rest and instruct the community in monastic tradition.
By the time of the saint's death, it numbered 400 monks.
In spite of his age and his desire for monastic withdrawal, Saint Boniface did not cease his activities.
In 743, he took part in a great Germanic council, convoked for the first time by Carlo
Mann's mayor of the palace in the kingdom of Austria, with a view to the resolving of
the many problems raised in the Frankish church by the reforms of Charles Martel and the struggles
among the aristocratic clans.
These troubles, over ecclesiastical organization, had opened the way to a resurgence of paganism
and to the influence of a good many Christians who prayed on the people's credulity.
The authority of the bishops was then confirmed, and they, under Boniface's jurisdiction,
were pledged to watch over the reform of their clergy, the observance of the holy traditions
and the struggle against superstition.
Some of the ecclesiastical properties kept by the nobles were returned, and unworthy
prelates were deposed.
This reform spread to the whole of the Frankish church and was confirmed at the council of
Soisons in 744.
Boniface sought to accomplish this work of the unification of the Frankish church and
made Cologne his sea, but, resistence by some of the clergy and the Frankish princes,
having hindered the realization of this project, he settled in the sea of mines in 747.
Alsace, Alemania, and the Trevs region continued to be organized on other principles with
the greater independence with regard to Rome, while Saks remained obscenately attached
to barbarian practices.
Carleman, having abdicated to become a monk at Monte Casino, Saint Boniface crowned his
brother Pippin III, the short, at Soison, thus inaugurating the Carolingian dynasty in
751.
With the passing of the years his apostolic artor burned nonetheless brightly, and he still
planned to go and continue the evangelization of the obstinate fridia.
Having placed his most beloved disciple, Loll, to succeed him in the sea of mines, he
took leave of his friends, and prophetically taking only a shroud in his luggage, set sail
on the Rhine.
After having spent the winter in Utrecht in a monastery directed by one of his disciples,
he, when spring came, took up his mission towards the most northerly regions of the land.
Fairly well received by the people, the missionaries baptized a certain number of pagans, but
on June 5th, 754, while he was preparing to proceed to their confirmation, a yelling
armed troop flung itself on their encampment, the saints' servants and companions attempted
to take arms and resist.
But Boniface placed himself in the middle of the fray, and exhorting his men not to render
evil for evil, he cried.
The day so long awaited has come at last.
The time fixed for our deliverance is at hand.
Let us take comfort now in the Lord.
Let us accept His decision, giving thanks to Him.
Trust Him.
He has already delivered your souls.
The barbarians' rage was only redoubled.
One of them brandished his sword, and cutting in two, the folio that the saint had held
up to protect himself, split his skull.
They massacred 52 of his companions, and slashed with sword strokes and hatchets, the reliquaries,
and books that the missionaries had as their only treasure.
Christians later came to gather their bodies, and the mortal remains of Saint Boniface were
taken to minds, and thence, following the saint's instructions to folder, which became
the pilgrimage center and the symbol of the unity of the German churches.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.